j'ai une très très grosse info à vous
annoncer le boss de qualcool Cristiano
allemande a annoncé officiellement il
l'a dit aux Figaro il a dit que l'année
prochaine et bien les smartphones de
Samsung les S23 probablement S23 S23
plus et S23 ultra dans le monde entier
n'auront absolument plus de processeurs
exinos de Samsung mais par contre ils
auront des snack dragon 8 GN2 et c'est
la première fois et c'est ça qui
vachement intéressant c'est la première
fois parce que si vous vous souvenez
jusqu'à maintenant qu'est-ce qui se
passait et bien pour le Canada et les
États-Unis on avait les professeurs de
malcol mais pour le reste du monde on
avait les processeurs exinos de Samsung
et ici ça va complètement changer donc
on aura des smartphones de Samsung qui
seront aussi puissants partout quel que
soit l'endroit où vous soyez dans le
monde c'est vachement cool parce que
l'info les dégainé avant même que ça me
saoule en parle avant même que
l'existence officielle de ces
smartphones soient révélés et je trouve
ça extrêmement dingue c'est pas une
rumeur c'est une info elle est donnée
par le boss de Qualcomm rien que ça et
ça mais ça c'est tellement dingue
tellement